ever get in a room full of stupid people
like you know you're at Thanksgiving
dinner and your relatives are all saying
something that's just absolutely
ridiculous I mean really stupid or
you're with some people at a party and
you realize you're at the wrong party
and so many people are just saying
moronic things and your eyes there's not
anything to say because if you say
something to them it's not going to do
any good because they've already made up
their mind to live neck deep in the
stupidity you know I'm talking about so
I got a friend of mine says when he gets
in one of those situations with like a
group of his relatives he just says like
his in-laws right he just says I just
assumed the bobblehead doll I just sit
there nod and smile and nod and smile
and smile like you know those bobblehead
dolls and we're talking about him and he
said there's no sense in arguing with
them so you might as well bobblehead
doll so I do not have the sound on
because I'm doing a radio show but we
keep several of the news feeds running
in here in case something breaks and
because I'm a DD and it gives me
something else to look at well up doing
this show so I'm watching whatever these
news feeds of this Senate confirmation
of the Supreme Court justice right and
you can tell that a bunch of these
politicians are just they need to be
seen they need to be heard they need to
make their ridiculous statement and
they're reading off these horrid you
know just do stupid crap these people
and the poor guy I mean what do you
agree with him or not he is holding his
composure what do you like all this
stuff or not he's just sitting he's
pretty much bobblehead dahling his way
through the stupid senators that are
parading in front of him I mean it's
just bless his heart
I just thought there's a bobblehead and
he really has composure because I
probably would just go all hillbilly on
the morons but um
he's just sitting there nodding his head
going you people are idiots
and he just comes into the nod his head
all yeah he's really got composure so
maybe that's what it takes to be a
Supreme Court justice because they
wouldn't let me be one I'd start war or
something but I'm not sure that the
Supreme Court has the ability to do that
but if I was there we could figure it
out
it's hitman I don't have the composure
to put up with those idiots in
Washington I just they call me up and
testify on something they're doing up
there and I said you don't really want
my opinion you just want to say I was
here you just want to say Dave Ramsey
said so and so about money that's all
you want you don't really want to know
what I think because you already know
what I think and none of you people are
going to do it like control your
freaking spending you know it's not
going to happen so I would be up there
bubblehead dialling and I'm not very
good at that so what's this guy's heart
I'm not turning this off it's
distracting hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]